Orleans is all about building on what's
happened for to build a stronger product
next time like with any Borderlands game
it's a gaming you can serve play with
some friends and sort of just hang out
and have a fun time with it not take
terribly seriously because it's a game
that doesn't take itself all that
seriously the first rule of dramas put
interesting characters together and let
them interact and I think that's one of
the things that bored lines is very good
at
but we really want to have move the
industry for the waterways
a lot of the things that were still kind
of lingering they just needed to get out
of us after we'd finished Borderlands 2
or able to get into Borderlands the
pre-sequel
in Borderlands 1 we just had a huge
number of weapons and when borderlines
to shut up we said okay well what are we
gonna do to keep the weapons fresh and
interesting we realize that what we need
to do is diversify them on another level
we needed to make the manufacturers more
distinct it was like okay well what done
fantasy are we not hitting we have
torque and they're all about explosions
they're about feeling like you're Arnold
Schwarzenegger in an 80s action movie TV
or is like you're buying guns from
Walmart how can we make this the
cheapest feeling unpossible when we
added the idea that when you reload you
throw it in explodes doll is is guns for
the career soldier for the mercenary who
wants a really really reliable gun that
doesn't have a lot of recoil Jacobs is
basically guns for cowgirls or Cowboys
only one our guns that are basically all
about elemental effects they they and
they're supposed to be really sleek and
sexy and very very sci-fi and Vladek was
the state that was appear to what it was
which is it's all about rapid fire rate
and being the most mature firing a lot
of bullets we're gonna have like some
lean like a long it might be sort of
more lasers may show maybe more have
Jacob style pistols and maybe some kind
of benefits there but we don't want to
walk people in we definitely want to
make people feel free to use whatever
weapon they feel is gonna be most
entertaining to use
I don't know how they managed to get to
borderlands games in and not have lasers
the opportunity for us to be the guys
that bring lasers to Borderlands it's
awesome so laser guns are in and of
themselves an entire weapon type so
there's four main manufacturers that
have laser weapon types as you move
between the different laser
manufacturers it completely changes the
type of weapon another one is the
traditional Ghostbusters style beam
weapon dull is the blaster style so
think of your Star Wars stormtrooper
hyperion is more kind of like a rail gun
so single sharp eye damage very accurate
and TDR is kind of like a split fame
kind of like a laser shotgun elemental
effects apply to all the weapons so you
can totally get a cryo laser where
you're shooting at an ice beam freezing
a guy and shattering him in one go every
leader has a different identity just
similar to Borderlands 2 that makes
finding new ones an exciting experience
now crave direct uh if we ever have a
meeting that isn't about lasers I think
he actually gets a little tear in his
eye he's so excited about lasers
whenever we talk about them it's really
fun for me to play a game work I'm
playing a Borderlands game and finding
guns that I don't know what they're
gonna do before I pick them up it's very
entertaining wait why the hell are we
playing this kids game fans probably
pretty knowledgeable about Borderlands
and post-launch support and this game is
gonna be no different we're sort of
talking a little bit about what else we
could do we want to have some more
content based fealty wanna we're still
finishing up the game swimming up too
deep into that but we have had a history
of supporting DLC and I think really
badass DLC tiny Tina it really showed
what you can do with the DLC pack and
we're interested to explore things like
that you know where we really turn
things in the head and then have a lot
of fun with what we do with 4 DLC packs
there's two things do things that make
borderline special I'm one of them just
math you can you can figure out fun with
math there's a lot of the design a lot
of the gameplay a lot of what happens is
understanding where the fun is in the
numbers Borderlands is a surprisingly
awesome and successful franchise and I
can say that because I didn't work on
the first game I just really really
enjoyed it as a player even then I sort
of felt like there was something special
here there's something that the guys
that made this game latched on to that
was just smart as hell and really
unpretentious one thing I've learned in
my career making video games is when
you're working with a group of talented
people whatever they're most passionate
about they're gonna make it great one of
the most important aspects of the
development of this was to let the folks
that have created a game be part of the
process was really interesting
collaboration it's been interesting it's
this project has evolved a lot since its
originally started and people have
gotten more excited and more excited as
we've seen what is growing into then
it's like wow you know making a full
Unreal Borderlands game which is to
people like me who are huge fans of the
franchise it's just really exciting it's
just great to see the fruits of valor
but kind of really coming together where
the skin it's a punk where is really
excited and we just can't wait to kind
of get out there and see what the public
thinks my hope is when we've launched
Borderlands the pre-sequel that maybe
maybe between our own minds and the
people now now down in 2k Australia
maybe some new exciting ideas will
emerge for the future and that that is
throwing it's the passion and the
craziness and the freedom of the people
who work here
and letting them take this universe and
make it their own every one of them
because